alright guys I did get a bunch of
requests asking me how to make the ninja
star or the shuriken so I'm going to
teach you how to do that today
I'd also like to teach you guys how to
make the original Japanese crane which
is also really fun to make possibly how
to do a rocket ship and this is also
really fun to make it's similar to
making the paper balloon but there are a
lot of more advanced folds involved the
ninja star is pretty simple to make
there's no real advanced folds or you
know pocketing or anything like that
it's kind of like making a football
except what you're going to do is you're
going to split this paper in half and
you're going to make two of these which
are then they're then going to fit into
each other in order to make your ninja
star so I'm going to show you how to do
that today and what you're going to need
is a piece of printer paper now scissors
are optional I'm not going to use them
in the tutorial because it doesn't
really matter if you have rough edges so
once you have a piece of paper you're
ready to begin alright there's a few
different ways that you can make a ninja
star one requires that you have a square
piece of paper now the way that I do it
I just use a full printer sheet that
doesn't require that you waste any of
the paper and what that does is it
actually makes it a little bit thicker
than some of the other ones that you
might find so it is pretty heavy and you
do have sharp ends so if you're going to
throw them just be careful not to hit
anyone that in the eye so what you want
to do is you want to hold the paper like
this and you're going to fold it in half
so grab this end fold it down and you
want it to go edge to edge you don't
have to be too neat about it but once
it's edge to edge you make a crease
and then you're just going to rip it in
half basically so just run your
fingernail against it a few times and
then you could rip it in half okay so
now you're going to make two identical
pieces which are then going to fit into
each other so I'm going to go through
with you how to make one of them and
then you're going to make the other one
and then I will show you how to put them
together and finish your ninja store
okay so once you split the paper in half
you want to hold it just like this so
that the longer ends are horizontal and
what you're going to do is you're going
to fold it in half so you meet the edge
to edge as always and make a crease then
you're going to fold it in half once
more making a horizontal fold
okay so you should have something that
looks like this
now what you want to do is you want to
fold it in half this way and you just
make a crease like that so now you
should have something that looks like
that so to make things a little bit
easier for you to see exactly where the
folds are occurring I'm just going to
make a line here at the halfway point
alright so now that you have the paper
that's folded in half like that what you
want to do is you want to hold it like
that horizontally and you're going to
take this edge here and you're going to
fold it on to that line and you want to
fold it down make a crease so you should
have something like that flip it around
180 degrees and you're going to do the
same thing with this end so you want to
fold it down on to that line okay so now
you should have something that looks
like that now what you do is you flip it
over completely just make sure it's nice
and flat you want to fold everything and
make good creases now what you're going
to do is you're going to take this end
and I'll make another line
you want to take this end of the paper
and you want to fold it onto that line
right where it meets this fold here okay
and you want to do the same for the
other side
okay so you should have something that
looks like that now what you're going to
do is you're going to take this corner
and you're going to fold it down into
this corner you want to take it and you
want to fold it just like that so that
it looks like that then you're going to
fold it straight down flip it around
take this corner fold it down into this
corner and you're going to fold this one
straight down also so you should have
looked something that looks just like
this and you're finished with making one
piece so now you're going to have to
make an identical piece and then we're
going to fit them together joining the
two pieces that we just created is
exactly the same thing as locking the
flaps of a box now some of you might not
know what I'm talking about but if you
take one flap put the next flap down the
next one and if you lift this one up and
you tuck this flap underneath the flaps
of the box are now locked and that's how
you can close a box without tape pretty
much so what you want to do is you want
to take the two pieces that you created
and as you'll see I drew little arrows
here this is a line here if you consider
this middle line here what you want to
do is you want to hold the one on the
right horizontally like that and you
want to hold this line vertically like
that then what you're going to do is
you're going to just open the flaps
and you want to just fit them inside
okay so now what you're going to do is
you're going to put this flap down first
and you'd like to put this one over it
so we're going to go in a clockwise
direction so this one should be all the
way in the middle on the bottom so one
then you do this one two then you do
this one three and then what this one is
going to go over this edge and it's
going to go under this edge here so you
kind of want to you want to tuck it in
there and then all you have to do is
kind of just flatten it out and there
you go you have a ninja star now it
might be a little bit tough for you to
kind of tuck it in all you got to do is
just just kind of lift it up a little
bit if you're having a little trouble
and you'll see that you should be able
to fit that last one in there alright
guys so I hope you enjoyed the tutorial
and I will hopefully have the Japanese
crane and the possibly the rocket ship
coming as well so just let me know what
you guys thought and thanks for watching